six mois dis moi que je me trompe
j'ai lu un article où il disait que tu
es né à vichy c'est vrai dans l'allier
c'est vrai ouais mon père et mon père
est musicien
ouais et il était chef d'orchestre au
casino de vichy et puis là-bas il est en
saison là bas il a fait juin juillet
août 70 tunnels de septembre s'est cassé
il emprunterait le alors mon papa non
dis moi et c'est vrai que tu as été
conçue sur le bateau qui revenait
d'afrique du nord je ne sais pas où ils
ont fait ça parce qu'ils m'ont on peut
parler mais je devais prendre pas être
loin dans un moment pareil
enfin vous avez le coeur aux galipettes
ses parents n'étaient pas sur le banc
lors du débat river à bord d'algérie
mais mais ils ont dû faire ça à
marseille
ouais alors tu es effectivement issu
d'une longue lignée de musiciens puisque
ton grand père dirige l orchestre
philharmonique de tunis il a fait ouais
il a fait mais il a fait des choses
comme ça à tunis il a dirigé des
orchestres il était premier basson alors
qu'est-ce que l'héroïne de tunisie il
était à la salle maltaise quelqu'un de
très important
ton père avait un orchestre à alger
ouais qui marchait très bien qu'il est
il a fait danser danser farrugia ton
oncle était chef d'orchestre de mireille
mathieu c'est vrai c'est vrai dans les
années 70 et la première fois que tu as
vu mireille mathieu s'est tu as fait
quoi
ben je sais plus j'étais trop petit puis
après ils ont pour montrer ce que j'ai
pleuré voulaient plus y aller tu as pris
la flûte
ouais la flûte traversière sait comment
les flûtes traversières un jeu comme ça
d'accord et puis tu es devenu batteur de
rock
ouais c'était parce que je voulais
devenir de rock'n'roll ouais et alors
bah voilà ce que je fais maintenant tu
en voilà on séparait ouais non mais
c'était vous l'êtes
je me souvient jean-luc tête je voulais
faire vedette et puis comme la batterie
ça me plaisait bien implique c'était
bien et puis comme j'ai toujours il ne
regrette rien ça se trouve indochine ils
sont même pas drôle
comme j'étais déjà un peu gros c'était
bien ça a aidé pour draguer un peu quoi
donc tirer un peu moins sur la plastique
commun hélas la chanson ça te tente
toujours une question pour lui c'est
chanter je sais chanter voir qu'est-ce
qui change pas je t'attendrai à la porte
du garage
tu parles est la principale route au
papa il faut la nuit mais malgré
l'éclairage pour un peu depuis le
courant voire jusqu'au 17
régulièrement ouais hein dis moi donc tu
t'es retrouvé je sais pas comment en
train de faire les bandes-annonces de
canal+ toi je suis rentré j'étais je
suis en taille quel allons en outre 84
g/t rtl d'abord j'étais de standardiste
puis après j'ai bossé avec max meynier
loyer et routiers sont sympas et max
dans sa grande bonté m'a fait rencontrer
dominique cantien je suis devenu
assistant dominique cantien et puis de
fil en aiguille j'ai fait les bons choix
fil en aiguille les fidèles et 8 et l'as
roma pour pension et là tu es devenu
je suis devenu nul ouais parce que c'est
pareil tu étais cherchiez et pour moi
c'est toujours toi qui parle dans les
interviews sorcier rien parce que je
suis un chercheur est une île
intelligent ça les énerve que tu parles
toujours comment ils s'en foutent c'est
bien mais c'est bien bien pensé moi je
parle mais ça leur pose chez durand
ouais tu as dit on et quand tu dis des
trucs mal et on est les anciens nouveaux
comics je veux pas lui faire marrer que
tu dis des trucs comme ça quand même
on est d'accord mais sait on est des
anciens nouveaux comiques ya s'est
endetté les nouveaux colis que va-t-on
les anciens nouveaux comme il l'a fait
c'est un way des inconnus c'est des
révolutionnaires j'ai lu dans le journal
ont séparé les moines les intervenants
patio leur nez je suis à 7 dt mois monde
le comité d'entreprise
la boucherie chevaline on est aussi des
topics
les permanences ici tout bête ça va
reprendre cinq minutes à moi je me tends
mais datant de lâcher venu voir ses
j'aime bien les inconnus quoi j'aime
bien ce que vous faites un c'est
formidable
il aime bien pis là je vois y avait deux
personnes d'obédience judaïque ça nous
fait un point commun ce monsieur dans le
show-business fouet
non je suis ton et qu'une personne les
personnes de couleur là bas les joue
actuellement
j'ai pris quelques données que vous
n'êtes pas poli de jeu c'est moche c'est
l'attitude que vous avez tu de moi pour
tout ce barouf on passe à six mois et
tout respecter cette loi
mais un beau [ __ ] ouais t'es un beau
[ __ ] quoi tu dis ça devant le char des
sens oui mais sa devancière ou 149 on
est un compétiteur du focal animateur
maison avec tout le respect que je vous
dois quitter ton vous [ __ ] ventilé
laurent battles manquait tant j'essaie
d'arrêter monsieur dumas payant veut pas
de moi
la bouffe c'est encore moins tout le
respect que je vous dois je m'appelle
jean pantaloni battus pas un animal mais
bon on ose plan dit de partir de
splendides et lui à partir du corps je
ne sais pas je connais pas va pas être
content à partir donc à partir de
maintenant 1 à 22 heures tous les soirs
et là on voit la vente est sensé est un
comique fin tu veux bosser là dedans pas
bon c'est vrai que pour moi ça n'a pas
toujours été facile nombreux témoins un
bon déjà bombay je suis né dans une
banlieue un petit peu quelqu'un bon
c'était difficile
inquiétude - aujourd'hui à ya eu des
départs de bombe de petite fille commis
la boulette en façon j'ai payé je suis
chez moi et tout le respect que je vous
dois vous en sortir
on fait des jeux pardon de la petite
fille dont il a été une vieille histoire
études moi c'est moi qu'est-ce que tu
payes de remuer le passé comme ça c'est
mark 1
enfin bon bref bon ben voilà c'était
juste pour m disons un point pour la
cfdt les passions - ch/la cndd bon et on
a des problèmes
on a de bons tous les travailleurs
salariés dans la boucherie chevaline ça
va pas nous moi je moi je suis dans la
couille de boeuf un bon la tétine de
chat on a des problèmes
bon c'est tout simplement on est venu
juste pour ça c'est tout pas si on sait
que l'émission est en direct ce sera pas
coupée à ça c'est pas de chez vous et je
vous remercie de l'émission là-bas merci
à tous les abus et comment
d'accord bomba après tout le service
public est ouvert à tout le monde le
service public c'est la télévision du
public c'est bien le chaînon cc cryptée
donc les mets qui passent moins tout le
monde peut s'exprimer
la preuve je